when you're quarantined like this and
all this is going on is it
impossible to write jokes i i do most of
my writing
on stage so it's just so
i mean i haven't gone this long without
stand up since if
my whole you know and since i was 17 you
know it's i really
i guess that's why i did started this
podcast it was just like i had no place
to
do this you know past titles of your
podcast i like this
jewy actors yeah who's a jewelry actor
like the parts i get to play you're
either uh
a sassy
friend of the main character who's just
in charge of exposition but you're a
lawyer and you love him
go on that date you know or you're this
[ __ ] girlfriend before the guy realizes
what love
really can be or you're that guy's book
agent
like sleazy book agent or our scumbag
executive
those are your partners yes and it's
funny because i was saying this to
somebody and he goes
what about woody allen movies and i go
tell me the jewish actresses in woody
allen movies
diane keaton mia pharaoh like
there are no jewish women in woody allen
who's irrelevant but
so in other words being jewy means that
you only get jewy parts
and then do you get upset when they give
away jewey parts to somebody who isn't
jewish actors are actors and they should
play all different parts a hundred
percent let me make that clear
right it's the collective of the fact
that if there is a role
that's a jewish woman which is rare as
it is but lately it's been happening
and if that role is a jewish woman
but she is courageous or
she is um deserves
love or has bravery or is
altruistic in any way she's played by a
non-jew
right right right i mean wow is that a
100 from gold
that's the thing is like i wouldn't care
one time two times 11 times
but every time i mean it's like they
finally make rbg
the movie and it's a british woman
felicity jones
you know they they miss maisel god bless
her she's brilliant not jewish like you
know
right even in jojo rabbit which i loved
nobody was jewish and that the jew in
the wall wasn't even jewish it was some
actors named mackenzie
then i know this is terrible to say but
so i've been watching the undoing
and i really like nicole kidman and i
really like hugh grant's great in it
and stuff yes and i go i'm just gonna
google the book this is based on
so i google the book it's based on has
some other title
they changed the last names of the main
characters
the main character's last name is like
rheingold sax or something
[ __ ] newest is it the biggest
injustice in the world
no but i just i'm noticing it